[Music]
a chinese rocket with
three astronauts aboard lifted off
overnight
and docked with china's new space
station a few hours later
that orbiting lab will compete with the
international space station which is
near the end of its expected life
raymien ascencio reports on this new
challenge for nasa
echoing the race to the moon and back in
the 1960s
with rockets flaring china made it clear
washington could not block beijing's
space ambitions forever
a decade after the u.s barred china from
the iss
citing national security the first three
astronauts to the nation's
own space station broke the bonds of
earth
they really are serious in wanting to
emerge as a very senior science power
for the benefit of all mankind this
spring china landed a rover
on mars just the second country after
the us
and china's space station called palace
of the heavens
is set for completion at the end of
2022.
thermal cover coming open the 23 year
old iss to be decommissioned just two
years later
but i suspect that america will actually
develop
its own capabilities and probably
keep the space station going longer
because it won't want to see china
having the only game in town
with china's ascent literally do you
think that's the
kick in the butt that the united states
space program needs i think it might
well be
i mean you know if you go back to the
50s and 60s it was a rivalry and
competition between
the soviet union and america that did
launch a real space race
to the moon half a century later
the space race is blasting higher with
more ambition
and competition for cbs this morning
raymien ascencio hong kong you know if
the u.s hadn't banned
china from the iss maybe the china
wouldn't be trying to make its own
competing space station competition is
good